hilarious thing about spring scene is  how much plastic surgery he's had and no  one notices I know it's everyone just  keep saying how he looks hilarious it's  like he's so spray tanned and botoxed up  and hair like the whole from top to  bottom he's like Madame Two Souls at  this point you wheel them in and uh did  you watch his did you go to his Broadway  thing no it was a good show yeah I  actually talked about oh so you watched  it yeah it's funny hearing someone talk  about their own myth and their own myth  making I know because that really struck  me because he's like I didn't really  grow up that way pretty much saying you  know I didn't I made a lot of this [ __ ]  up yeah spring seed could tell people  that's not who I am in the go yeah you  are yeah what are you gonna what are you  gonna play Born to Run yeah yeah like  seriously you were you had like a girl  and you would yeah yeah it's like they  they like the character